let's bring you the latest pictures that
we have from Philadelphia and this is
the train crash that happened late last
night u.s. time it happened around train
leaving Washington around 7:00 in the
evening due to get to New York around
half 10:00 these are the first daylight
pictures that we have of the crash it's
now 5:00 to 6:00 in the morning there
you can see the scene of the wreckage at
least five people have died and dozens
have been injured when this train
derailed overnight another six from a
critical condition there were 10
carriages on this train nobody knows
what caused the crash yet what caused it
to come off the rails so
catastrophically last night but it was
around 9:30 in evening when it crashed
in the Port Richmond area people had to
climb out of windows out of the back of
carriages to survive when you look at
just five dead with 260 on board it is
astonishing when you see the wreckage
but so few people actually perished in
that the the train was quite busy they
are not going to be any Amtrak services
through Philadelphia now for the rest of
the week but these are the first
daylight pictures that we have of the
train crash in Philadelphia yesterday
evening